Donald Trump Supreme Court nominee Neil
Gorsuch or as I'm referring to him bland
derson Cooper faced his second
confirmation hearing today it's very
good thing this is Comedy Central
because he came ready to bring with the
last people take a look she could teach
a monkey how to read I think she did
I wrote this a hundred page book on
takes a great doorstop gift for
Christmas I kind of really bad deal on
loyalty the role does mean something to
me and not just as I could hide the
coffee stains on my shirt all right
he's already disobeying the Constitution
because these jokes are cruel and
unusual punishment
comedians he's clearly aiming for a
career as a stand-up so at the comedy
club emcee I would like you to introduce
um Jeff garbage Emily I give it up for
your bar and waitstaff they all just
lost their health insurance